[Music]
I'm the one
okay so today's guest Sam Cedar a lot of
you guys were asking to have them on
after we had the
all these guys on they said why don't we
get Sam on samrawn's a show called The
majority report
uh with Sam Cedar he's got a big YouTube
channel 1.2 million uh two four million
subscribers we just found out he was a
big Banker at Goldman Sachs huge but he
does have a bear uh yeah you do have a
good story maybe you'll share that with
the audience what happened we'll get
into that here in a second so thanks for
being on on the podcast uh my pleasure
thanks for having me down here so uh we
got a lot of things going on right now
just yesterday if you just bought the
Wall Street Journal uh today this is
what the uh opening story is on the
cover of it
fed boost rates amid Bank turmoil Powell
calls financial sector sound but
stressed uh stresses oversight the
concern becomes whether you know they're
saying they're going to protect
depositors what everybody's talking
about depositors depositors depositors
will they protect the banks or not we
don't know we'll talk about it maybe
people will have some opinions on it Sam
if you don't mind for the audience that
doesn't know you maybe share a little
bit about your background uh I am uh
I've been doing uh a podcast YouTube for
well and I was a first in am talk radio
starting about 18 years ago uh prior to
that I was a uh a writer comedian
director in Showbiz and sort of stumbled
into uh talk radio on air America radio
and
grew up in Worcester Mass and that's I
like the Red Sox how did that happen how
did it happen from going from acting
from Comedy from writing to it was a
total fluke I mean as a kid I was
involved in in government like I had uh
I I did an internship in in DC and in
the the Connecticut state house and I
was a government major and I was
involved in Municipal politics in
Worcester Mass when I was in high school
but I also had a dual track of like
doing sort of theatery stuff and when I
left uh I went to law school for a year
left to do comedy with a buddy of mine
and
then about 14 years later Janine
Garofalo who I was friends with said she
had this opportunity to do uh political
Talk Radio in the uh run up to the 2004
election and I just thought I'll do it
for six months
um and get back to uh to show business
and I enjoyed it and uh so and during
that time I got married and my wife got
pregnant and so I decided that's that's
what I would what I would say I mean I
still did some show business stuff
probably as late as 2012 and I'm I'm
still a voice on Bob's Burgers which is
a cartoon but that is just sort of what
are you doing Bob's Burgers Hugo I'm uh
a couple of couple of characters that's
cool what's a bigger passion politics or
entertainment I mean they can kind of uh
you know Collide but what's movies shows
actually I would say politics are
probably more of a passion for me I mean
you know I had fun in the entertainment
world and I do have a little bit like I
I see with my friends who have all uh
been not all but many uh very successful
and I like their lifestyle but uh I I
find politics more stimulating and and I
I interview a lot of like um on my show
uh policy experts authors uh historians
and so it's like every day I get paid to
come in and learn something new and I
like that did you ever have like I'm
gonna go into politics or is it more you
know doing a show
uh there were times where I thought
about it I mean there were times where I
thought about it as a kid maybe not
enough money in it what was the
reasoning to say I'm not going to do it
was it just like I'm I'm more gonna be
from the outside than the inside uh no I
I think it was you know the the you know
I did a lot of like political stuff in
college and I felt like on some level it
was a little bit constraining but there
are times I've contemplated it
since you're in politics pretty actively
now on the political Spectrum where
would you say that you identify not the
current form of identification with the
hishi we they them like political
Spectrum if there was a football field
where do you stand like 50-yard line
left right where do you where I'm I'm
definitely of the left without it how
far left
you know I don't I don't know I mean are
you in the red zone are you are you near
the goal line are you closer to the 50.
you know I don't know I don't I don't
really think about it too much in those
terms to be honest with you I mean I
think that like uh uh I I think a
genuine socialist would say I'm
certainly not a socialist
um I don't know uh you know but I I I
have no problem with how people identify
me in that way I mean I I'm really more
interested in a set of policies and
really ultimately just the outcome of
what will create the best outcomes for
the most amount of people
for me that's and and you know
there's a couple different ways of
saying that but that's basically what it
boils down to me as a as a kid who was
your guy like if you were to say this is
the book that influenced me this is the
guy that I liked the way he spoke you
know this is the the TV guy or the
president or the politician or who was
your guy uh I would say uh I was very
moved by the autobiography of Walter
Mondale and I'm joking
you like land
liked Clint Eastwood movies when I was a
kid I mean I didn't really realize much
about him the person but I like those I
like the Spaghetti Westerns and stuff
like that but I guess what I'm asking is
you know morph because you said you were
in politics in high school like you were
interested in government from earlier on
what was a source of inspiration was
there somebody you looked up to was it
kind of like like if you and I were in
high school together in 10th Grade who
was Sam
um I I I think people thought I was a
little bit nerdy
people thought you were a little nerdy
yeah did they think you would go into
Hollywood and act or no
um I got uh I think I got like voted
Class Clown really yeah that makes three
of us yeah I think I did yeah but I also
um you know I was I was in I was working
for the Worcester Charter commission at
the time which was starting to like
reassess how they were going to
apportion votes in the city and so I
don't know I don't I don't I tend not to
have like uh Heroes per se I don't I
don't find that healthy really no I
don't think so I think people get too uh
caught up in the personalities of
politicians and really sort of Miss
um what what would that what is actually
going on so no Heroes as a kid you don't
have any Heroes you didn't like He-Man
you didn't see you know Rocky well Rocky
would have been what 19
[Music]
um
I was a kid uh yeah you must have had
Larry Bird on your list come on Larry
Birds
gonna go sports like bird I Loved Bird
and uh I was a fan of McHale in Paris as
well I got very excited about
um Russ Francis on the Patriots uh Bobby
Orr on in hockey
um but
you know I I remember uh I'm not going
to say his name but I met a uh a guy I
was a fan with on the Red Sox in person
and I was like I wish I had Madam
because in person I'm just not that
impressed I like what he does on the
field so does he kind of look like you
oh the the guy you're saying that uh
because there's a Mets guy that looks
like you no he wasn't sorry I didn't
look like okay got it because I know
you're talking about the the okay
anyways very cool I met my father that
Dad very cool so okay that sounds good
let's go into uh uh the the Silicon
Valley Bank story what do you think is
uh going on there and do you think it's
the end of it obviously yesterday Powell
came out a lot of people didn't think if
he's going to increase interest rates or
not right is this guy gonna do it is he
not gonna do it you know it's not a good
time to do it maybe take a break for a
month or two you know we're seeing what
happened with uh Silicon Valley Body I
don't know 10-year bond for a hundred
billion dollars at one point seven
percent thinking they're gonna make it
and then bam they have to sell that for
some 20 billion dollars and and you know
do
depositors are afraid those below a
quarter million which is a small
percentage whatever the number was three
percent they're covered but the ones
above everybody's coming and saying we
got to build the depositors out what are
your thoughts about what's going on
um well there's a couple of different
issues I mean and and you can sort of go
down the line the the biggest issue is
is that in 2017 uh the Trump
Administration the Republicans and with
some corporate Democrats as well
basically rolled back the regulations
that were required for banks like sbv it
used to be if you had 50 billion dollars
worth of Holdings as a bank you were
subject to the Dodd-Frank requirements
about Capital to keep the bank safe uh
and that would have also come along with
like sort of subsidiary uh uh
regulations and and Regulators being
there to make sure that you can't make
stupid decisions like that I mean they
made some very stupid decisions uh that
were uh that you know people involved in
banking could take issue with assuming
that interest rates were always going to
stay low whatever the point of
regulations like that where you take
more or less a meat cleaver and you say
is that people can make stupid decisions
but we're going to be here to protect
the system and the depositors the other
thing that was going on there with with
all the deposits had all this other
money this is a kickback situation
there's no doubt about it right because
you you know anybody with 251 thousand
dollars
cash knows that there is a 250 000 FDIC
limit and if you're putting half a
million dollars in there or billions of
dollars in there you're getting
something from the bank in return which
is low-cost business loans or like zero
percent mortgages I'm sure you run into
this you put your money into some big uh
you know uh Investment Bank you're
getting Kickback you're getting a zero
percent mortgage so you go out buy a 13
million dollar house you don't have to
pay anything for that money you keep
your money in a CD and you're still
you're making money off of that 13
million dollar house essentially that
you bought because you've just got that
money borrowed cheap and if they're
gonna do that I mean look
teach their own if they're going to do
that they need to pay the consequences
they took a risk I'm gonna put my money
in an uninsured uh bank because I'm
getting back all this like you know and
sometimes I think it was like they did
this with their businesses and then they
get the personal mortgages which is also
it's just a kickback so I say we don't
bail those people out because we have
the rules and these are the rules now a
lot of these people are big names they
have the ability to go on to every show
that exists on TV and whatnot and claim
that this is going to be a systemic risk
but I don't believe that frankly
um
and so you know I I think what we need
to do and nobody's talking about it is
put the regulations back we have now
proved that it's dangerous
um uh to have rolled back the
regulations on these mid-sized Banks and
so uh you know the the deafening Silence
about it is amazing to me so Sam let me
ask you based on what you just said so
your uh so obviously we know the guys
below quarter million they're covered
but it's a small percentage with Silicon
Valley Bank it's not like it's a big
number the people above quarter million
uh with these guys that are coming out
saying hey we gotta you got we gotta
take care of these depositors because if
we don't you know all these other
smaller communities and regionals are
going to get hit these 27 regionals we
have one is gone now it's 26 they're
going to remove their money and they're
going to put it in the big Banks this is
one of the ways to nationalize it and
we're going to go through only five
banks and all this stuff so the people
above the quarter you're straight up
saying if you had more than a quarter a
million anything you had let's not back
them up let's not protect them they lost
the money I think there is that danger
that you talk about that there could be
a run on these other I think it's
overstated but
um I I think there is a danger and I
think the way that you deal with that is
you come out you say
we're going to make sure that we're
going to subject these 23 other
mid-sized Banks to the kind of
Regulation that we uh that we um impose
upon the bigger Banks so that the
security you feel with those bigger
Banks we're going to provide that
security for you by by regulating and
making sure that they have the capital
requirements that they need to protect
your money
okay so then go to if I give you like a
cause of uh to say it's this person's
fault let's go through rankings of it
okay below quarter million they
obviously didn't do anything you know
wrong there the guy's above a quarter
million dollars in savings then you have
the people that own shares in the
company they're shareholders of the
company then you have employees that
work for Silicon Valley bank then you
have the employees where the companies
who banked with Silicon Valley Bank
where the payroll is stuck and they
can't pay the payroll then you have the
politicians coming up with the
guidelines the regulations if you were
to put the blame on those folks and who
to take care of who not to take care of
who would you put at the top who would
you put at the bottom well I I don't I
mean I don't know how to apportion blame
amongst those things but I can tell you
this the the but for uh in that
situation is clearly uh the lack of
Regulation right I mean I don't know who
screwed up in in in in all of those
different levels but I know that if the
regulation if they were subject to those
same Capital requirements none of that
stuff would have happened in the first
place
yeah you know it's it's it's kind of
tough to debate that because I've been
an insurance business for 20 some years
right you don't see a lot of insurance
companies going out of business because
insurance companies Capital requirements
are a lot higher than Banks requirements
Banks can be a little bit more we saw
what happened in oh wait with the whole
no income no assets hey Sam how much
money made last year 72 Grand Sam one
more time how much money did you make
last year 72 Grand Sam one more time how
much money did you make last year right
158 okay great I'm Kevin a bank Sammy I
got 28 000 in the bank one more time how
much you have on a Mac 380 perfect no
income no assets and then bone the ninja
loan ninja loans right everybody takes
it so there's a part of that that
um I agree with the whole Ninja alone
you know it was never supposed to before
uh low and middle income families the
ninja alone if I recall came from
Australian Bank it was something they
were using and we brought it to the
states and it was supposed to be more
for like the you know the clients at the
Gold men and the higher and then they
said let's launch this to everybody out
there in the streets yeah you're a bank
loan officer right like I mean there was
a fiduciary responsibility by the person
in in that scenario there who kept
saying like
you know put the number up because I you
know I I come in for a mortgage I don't
know I don't I mean I'm not I'm not a
financial whiz you know who we had here
on the podcast uh four months ago very
uncomfortable podcast
uh it was with the former CEO of WAMU I
don't know if you remember WAMU
Washington oh yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah and that that thing was a behemoth
of a bank right 330 billion I think as
far as I well we we have Carrie
Killinger by the way he was kind enough
to come in I didn't know what he thought
we were going to talk about I banked
with WAMU for years and I loved one more
I thought it was a phenomenal experience
you'd go there you know uh the customer
service the way you would feel like
you're not at a bank there's not a
window where you feel like hey you can't
shoot us everybody was open there was a
relationship thing that was going on
I said what caused this you know why get
so reckless about it why what made you
think some of these things you were
doing with the amount of money that you
had were you ended up selling it for
Chase so I guess and I don't know how
much you follow uh the stories obviously
you're a guy that's been following every
story every day because this is what you
do for a living
what have we learned from oh wait
that we're not repeating today maybe
even the way Janet Yellen and the FED is
handling the bailout model their carnal
different thing what's different about
it today than it was in a way in your
eyes well I mean the situation is very
different too I mean I think you know
the the the amount of Leverage that
we're talking about in the system is
just not nearly the same and a lot of
those a lot you know Dodd-Frank uh
eliminated a lot of the more risky uh
stuff but you know again
I can tell you more importantly what we
didn't learn is when we rolled back
those regulations
you know like uh you and I we could we
could go through that whole thing we
could spend six months examining every
aspect of what what happened there and
we might come up with a different uh you
know who was really responsible or there
could be shared responsibility but the
bottom line This is why you need
regulation just like you said in the
insurance industry you have the tighter
regulation on this stuff you don't allow
for people to come in and play fast and
loose with all this stuff to gamble like
they're at the the race track and and
then come for a bailout from us because
look the bottom line is I know it comes
from FDIC fees but who's going to get
those fees
it's going to be it's and actually the
fees that are going to be imposed upon
people to bail out guys like David sacks
and all these other like uh uh you know
uh right-wing so-called libertarian
they're suddenly Libertarians looking
for the government handout but the
people are going to be paying off these
fees more than anybody else are lower
income people because they are stickier
with banks they don't have the
opportunity to go around they don't have
the time they don't have the inclination
The Savvy to go around and shop around
Banks where they're going to get lower
fees maybe they don't have the same
amount of deposits in there so they're
not going to be so that's who's going to
get stuck with this bill I want to
continue with this but let me go to our
sponsors real quick okay and this is so
interesting with the sponsor obviously
with all the stuff that's going on uh uh
I've been in the financial industry now
for 22 23 years and for the longest time
I was very skeptical about alternative
Investments I was like nah you straight
stocks real estate is kind of what you
look at and you saw the last few years
more and more people are looking at all
alternative Investments Masterworks what
it does is it allows you to buy shares
in high-end art maybe you can't buy five
million dollar Bank C or a Picasso
painting but you can buy a share into it
they're allowed they're allowing uh
folks to do this like Blue Chip art to
invest into uh I think when you look at
the numbers last year art Prices rose on
average 29 percent per uh Barons uh
everything you do with these guys has
gone through the SEC and it's broken
into share so it's the same exact where
you buy stocks as you do through
Masterworks if this is of interest to
you and you have a small percentage of
your portfolio you want to put and
consider into alternative Investments
you may want to look into Masterworks
Rob if we can put the link below uh
their website let me read their website
where we have here masterworks.art
forward slash pbd podcast one more time
masterworks.org forward slash PVD
podcast but we'll also put the link
below for you to join so let's go back
to this on what we can find default with
we can say you know we need more
regulation is what we need we can say
you know it's it's the greedy Banker's
fault you know we can say hey why are
you being so reckless you're putting all
your money in the bank you should never
put all your money in the bank right you
got to kind of diversify and put a
little bit more money there's also
something called sweeps and everybody
who's involved in a business knows this
I'm sure you know this that there are
third parties out there who will
distribute those 250 000 they have that
they have those money there for a reason
and that I think it was Kickbacks I
think it's probably going to come out in
a couple of months after more
investigation but again we don't have to
do we don't have to spend our time
worrying about who's to blame of those
individuals maybe they all know this is
where I was going how old were you when
you bought your first house do you
remember I was let's see it was in 98
okay so you got 20 26 35 yeah perfect so
25 years old what was the interest rate
when you got in 90 if you remember
I was an actor I didn't I just you know
I had a business manager at the time I
was making a lot of money I was just
like just you were limited yeah exactly
but don't worry about that can you go to
1998 average 30-year mortgage I don't
know let's just Google it and see what
the number was I imagine it was probably
around probably similar to what it is
what I'm thinking yeah I'm trying to see
what it was okay 6.91 yeah very simple
there you go okay six one by the way I
think that's where it needs to be for
about a decade
think the number needs to be there and
if you ask me quite if you ask me I
think we need to go a little bit more
old school in the way we buy stuff right
meaning how much down payment you got I
got this much down payment great you
know and now you may disagree with that
and say that's not going to be fair to
loan middle-income families but I think
there's part of it also the guidelines
to buy stuff has degree decrease the
guidelines to lend out money has
decreased you know money became so cheap
for such a long time where people were
going out to getting money left and
right what are your thoughts on that
what about mortgages no it's a lot
stricter than it was let's say uh 15 20
years ago I mean it's much harder you
need to provide much more documentation
and and the the loan companies are far
more stricter I mean they're not quite
where they were in the wake of the
financial crisis but they're still
pretty tight I mean the the problem I
have with the with the raising of the
interest rates is basically what Jerome
Powell says every time he does it which
is we need to get more people unemployed
and that's I mean in in look
we can argue as to whether uh the the
FED has the tools it needs to fight
inflation in this instance I happen to
think I have a new uh you know uh I I
don't even know if I I agree so much or
or just like the FED itself
says that uh the inflation that we went
through
only about 30 percent of it was a
function of Demand right the other uh
you had uh a significant portion of it
was a function of logistics and like
mismatch uh products and and this and
that with because of covid right it
wasn't a question that we didn't have
the productivity uh or the capacity uh
to meet uh demand it was just that it
was mismatched for a long time you're
sending shipping containers to places
you had never sent it before to get them
back is a lot more expensive these
things are starting to work through the
system wages contribute a little bit
because there has been some wage growth
for the first time in decades
essentially
a lot of it is also uh uh maybe the
plurality of it this is based upon the
FED numbers is basically just the
corporation seeing the opportunity to
raise these rates and so the FED comes
in they have one tool to deal with
inflation and that is you know they're a
hammer except for I'm arguing that it's
not a it's not a nail that they're
hitting it's a screw and they're doing
this in my estimation as a way of
weakening labor they are going to kick a
million how would you do it how would I
do it well I would deal with it fiscally
or I would just wait I would wait
because you're starting to see the
trends all moving the right direction in
terms of inflation and I would wait
um and and so you wouldn't have raised
the the I would have probably done maybe
half of what they'd done maybe two and a
half whatever the number is yeah you
mean the most recent no no no no
whatever's happened look at it today
right like they're worried about the
banks at the same time they're like
desperate to like we need to we need to
kick a million two million three million
people out of work that I mean they're
explicitly saying this and so uh you
know I
that does not make sense to me Sam a guy
here Scott Rodriguez just said sorry but
eighty percent of the loans given the
last three years only required five
percent down payment it was much harder
to get a loan in the 90s in in in terms
of mortgages yeah it's conceivable that
it was harder to get a loan in the 90s
I'm comparing it to like the odds
um but I can tell you I mean like I I
have some very close we think it's
better do you think it's a better
guideline to put a minimum 25 for
anybody to buy a loan or no five percent
down payment is fine I mean I think I I
I don't know if the the number is 10
percent or twenty percent I'd have to
like read in to see you know where we're
talking about foreclosures but we're not
having a foreclosure problem right now
now not yet because if he keeps raising
the interest rates and decreasing the
value of homes uh at this type of
rapidity you know uh rapid rate we might
but you know the way you avoid that is
don't do that so let me read this about
what happened uh this is an Insider
story The Fed May provide as much as a
two trillion dollar in liquidity relief
for banks after Silicon Valley collapse
JP Morgan says uh Chase estimates that
the federalism may need to inject two
trillion dollars into the U.S banking
system after the collapse for uh of
three lenders last week this would help
prevent a run-on deposits and address uh
the scarcity issue in the U.S banking
caused by the U.S fed the monetary
policy the feds Bank term funding
program the btfp is an emergency loan
mechanism that will allow Banks to
obtain liquidity by putting up their
bond Holdings as collateral the FED will
accept a bond at face value instead of
their current market value has not been
qualified by the FED yet but it is
accepted expected to be significant
enough to cover all uninsured deposits
in the U.S JPMorgan estimates that this
is going to be around seven trillion
dollars but suggests that the five
largest banks are unlikely to use the
program which would bring the actual
amount the FED provides to closer to two
trillion dollars does this sound like a
bailout why yeah of course okay why are
those big five banks not taking the
money because they have been subjected
to the Dodd-Frank regulations and they
haven't been able to get them themselves
in this type of situation so to be clear
the feds raising rates this fast
explicitly to make more people
unemployed in this country explicitly to
do that that's explicitly they're going
their goal is to reduce inflation that's
their first goal no that's a byproduct
no no that no no look it's not a
byproduct any more than me like taking
my hammer slamming it on your hand and
saying
both of you are right but Powell when he
was asked if you remember to hear him
when he was asked he says you realize
and I think it was Kennedy that asked
him Senator Kennedy that said hey you
realize what you're doing is to fix the
economy you have to lower the
unemployment and then what did he say
Powell said
that could be a cause of it but that's
not why we're doing it it says no no
that's why you're doing and I know
you're not a Kennedy guy because he's a
Republican side but he's like no no
that's exactly what you're doing
everybody knows it it doesn't matter
Republican Democrat anybody who's honest
knows exactly that's what the plan is
but do you really think that's the plan
do you really think the plan explicitly
the plan I think he said today by the
end of 2023 when you to have a million
people out of out of work I mean why
would they do that if they know it's
going to hurt the economy
because they they have one tool to deal
with inflation and that is to raise
interest rates as a way of cooling the
economy and cooling the economy and and
frankly I mean this is the charitable
view I'm articulating the charitable
View and to cool the economy means as a
byproduct
uh that you're going to kick people out
of work in my estimation this is the
first time we've seen any type of wage
growth in decades in decades right the
the the the wages versus productivity
has been out of sync for decades and I
think frankly uh people don't want labor
to have any power you're seeing
increased unionization you're seeing
increased work action you're seeing
people saying like you know yes I
definitely you really think that I think
how is playing politics in increasingly
it's not politics this is what it is
though Union is a formal pipe your
policies Powell is one of the most
powerful men in the world today you know
that I know that right so when he moves
the uh he's controlling one of the most
important knobs right which is the rates
without a doubt yeah so but I'm trying
to think myself like I'm trying to sit
there and say okay you know when they
gave 1.7 trillion dollars in uh you know
relief hey we're gonna do this we're
gonna do that or during coven hey we're
going to give 2.1 trillion we're going
to send people this much of money this
this that hey are they all they're
trying to do is they're gonna they're
trying to get people not to work right
that's what they're trying to do are
they really or were they doing it
because they're like dude I'm not
letting you work from home so I have to
send some money to you if you're getting
unemployed and I just laid off how many
people at the restaurant were
restaurants were crushed by uh covet
well I got to kind of take care of you
but then what happened with the money
the money went into the rich because you
know the low-income middle income
doesn't know how to save money and they
spend the money they're trying to make
it ends meet so sometimes you think from
the policies and you say oh they're
trying to do something really bad
you think Powell has negative intentions
or well he just sees this as a I don't I
I don't
I don't think I don't I don't think any
of this I have a different perspective
on how all this works I don't think that
Powell is sitting there going like it's
going to negative I just don't think
that these people care
I mean how do look how look we attacked
Iraq right 20-year anniversary yesterday
or two days ago
by anybody's estimates
we killed
hundreds if not hundreds upon hundreds
of thousands of innocent civilians
why
at this point this story we both aren't
the same page on we know what right
exactly yeah but but how is it that that
decision was made they don't care
about you that human loss and I don't
think Powell at the end of the day
really cares enough about the
immiseration of millions of people he
thinks the most important thing for the
stability of society is to save the
bankers Sam do you think I just disagree
Sam do you think do you think it was
healthy for us to go on a
128 month economic expansion only to be
disrupted by covet it would have
continued into honor you think it was
healthy to have interest rates as low as
we bid for over 10 years I mean I think
there's an argument that you could have
crept them up uh you know uh slowly you
know up a couple of percentage points
but but I was also told listen in the
Arts when I started this job you know
you sound like the capitalist If you
defend that why I don't care what I
sound like I mean when uh during uh
during the the odds I was told that the
the lowest rate of unemployment we can
have in this country is six percent if
we have it lower than that then the
whole thing falls apart do you remember
that of course we were told that was the
after like nature only allows that and
then all of a sudden that we can have uh
more unemployment I mean less
unemployment we could have three percent
I mean that they there we are presented
by uh you know the these Powers
um ideas that happened that that
basically they're in a closed loop with
just other people who have power and
money and have decided that this is just
sort of the natural state of being and
it's not I I just I I just disagree with
that premise okay so but let me go back
to this it's very important I want to
make this point I'm going to ask you
this a 128 month expansion is it fair to
say during that period when rates were
as low as they were
they benefited capitalists they
benefited someone's phone is uh if you
guys put such a point aside from the mic
yeah you know it's typically Verizon
whoever's Verizon ATT doesn't do its
only Verizon but you know it's it's that
that benefited that benefited the
capitalist because money was cheaper
right so to argue your argument saying
Well a true socialist would say I'm not
a socialist but I'm on the left you're
not for you know making it that easy for
those guys right so money was so
freaking cheap for so long that we have
to pay a price for it and now you're
looking at the economy it looked like
everything was good but a big part of it
was fake Sam we had a lot of fake
success the last few years well I mean
look I I'm just measuring on again my my
the way I view things is what's going to
make uh things better for the most
amount of people and in terms of like
you know it being in favor of the
capitalists I would also change our tax
policy so I mean I would claw some of
that back uh quite a bit of it back what
would you do uh I would return to the
tax policy when we had the greatest sort
of the widest
um uh economic expansion shared by more
people as a percentage of our population
than any other time in this country
which was in the 50s and the 60s and I
would return to the tax rates more or
less there so your your top tax rate at
that time was 90 percent top marginal
rate for every dollar over four hundred
and seventy thousand dollars you would
earn so that would be equivalent to
around three million dollars today I
think we should return to that type of
tax tax wanted to go as high as 90 at
the top marginal time at the top
marginal tax rate so understand like you
that only kicks in with every dollar
above 3 million I hear you and yeah I
mean that's the famous Reagan situation
where I think it was over anything over
two hundred thousand dollars at that
point this might have been in the 40s
that he would only do two movies a year
because you get paid 100 Grand per movie
and then he would even do a third movie
because he would only get 10 percent
of the revenue because he and he's like
[__] it I'm not doing another movie yeah
so when Reagan when Reagan started
telling that story you know who he was
working for when he started telling that
story right he was going around I think
it was if we're working for GE trying to
convince people not to get Medicare for
all I mean if Reagan could have gotten
three movies five movies he would have
done it he was working with chimps he
would have been happy to do that for his
career believe me so leave me you what's
the top marginal tax rate right now 39 I
think it's 37 39 I will say this though
just to finish up that Reagan story I
will say this to you uh uh I remember
being in LA and taxes Top Line had hit
whatever the all-in was 57 and a half I
don't know what the number was around 57
and have you uh you no you live in
Brooklyn uh so 57 and a half percent
people were like what the hell is going
on here there was this girl who was a
top realtor in the San Fernando Valley
area one of the top realtors her picture
was on all the benches everywhere you
would go you would see her and she was
one of the Realtors making very good
money she's making half a million dollar
your income doing good for us or
whatever the number was 400 500 000 one
day uh I stopped seeing her pictures on
the uh the the seats and I'm at Wood
Ranch with my wife and I said hey uh are
you you're the girl right she says yeah
I am she's with her husband her two kids
I said what happened we haven't seen you
lately since it's so funny you asked my
husband and I made a decision
that the moment taxes got so high it was
more important for me to be stay home it
wasn't worth me working to pay this much
in taxes so so there's a part of what
he's saying yeah whatever whether he's
going to do the movies I guess there's a
part of it that kind of I guess to be
there America would not have suffered by
the lack of Ronald Reagan movies
no but no but I would also argue that
like I bet you I guarantee you there was
no less houses that sold because that
one particular broker stopped selling
houses at a certain point
so go go to it so right now I don't
think that's a problem I really don't I
mean I think to raise it to 90 yeah no I
don't think I think I'm talking about is
sort of the Laffer Curve actually right
yeah you know you loved our Africa you
you're a big fan of it apparently I'll
tell you what I love about the laugher
curve is that we had a perfect example
of we had a almost like a perfect model
of what happens with the Laffer Curve
right like the Laffer Curve argues that
the higher the tax rate goes the less
inclined people are going to be to
generate income and then uh because
they're generating less money there's
going to be less tax receipts
collected by the government
art Laffer was uh Sam brownback's number
one advisor in Kansas do you remember
this when Brownback became Governor he
basically gave over his entire tax
structure to Art Laffer
they had such a it destroyed the tax
base in Kansas it ended up destroying
their entire education system they had
an amazing Kansas University Brownback
gets plucked out of Kansas and literally
sent to be ambassador to Ether you know
what they made him ambassador to Faith
because they didn't want this guy around
at all the republican-controlled uh
Kansas legislature raised taxes back up
yeah because it had destroyed their tax
receipts the theory may sound good but
it doesn't work in practice so are you
on YouTube and rumble or just YouTube
I'm on YouTube I think we put it on
Rumble I think we're also on Twitch and
I think all over the place okay so yeah
let me ask you this question uh if
YouTube took their AdSense from 55 to 15
would you continue creating content
yeah you sure sure you'd continue
creating I wasn't doing YouTube for a
long time how do you make a living today
I have membership uh I have membership
that people uh pay I get ad revenue from
different places okay so let's just say
the membership that you get from patreon
or whoever it is okay what if their fees
went from them keeping five percent to
sixty percent to ninety percent would
you continue creating content I mean I I
I I would I would probably have to uh
cut back if there was exactly well but
that's only because it's such a big
change that's the that's the part about
it Sam so your audience guesses I'm not
saying we'll cut the revenue for these
businesses I'm saying that the amount of
you don't have no choice though because
you're paying these guys you need the
revenue no no I'm not suggesting we cut
revenue for businesses what I am
suggesting is after that Revenue comes
in and we divvy up and I have my net
profits then my taxes would go up but I
will say this like if let's say the
taxes went up on me personally would I
would I stop uh going on YouTube no
so would you be able to scale it at the
how many employees you got working for
you right now I'm not talking about
about Revenue I get that how many
employees are you working are working
for you right now uh we have payroll I
think like six or seven okay you got six
that's a small business you got there
right shirts or seven people okay if all
of a sudden
uh AdSense went up the fees for your
patreon I keep I don't want to offend
you when I say patreon I don't know who
you use whoever you use that's got your
membership stuff that that you get we
use fans FM okay there you go that's a
shout out to them so fans FM fans dot fm
okay fantastic so if they raise it less
than patreon if they take 50 all of a
sudden and these they say YouTube says
AdSense goes to 15 would you be able to
employ those six people
no if my if my well I don't know but but
probably maybe that's because you're
rich no no probably probably not but but
but I'm not suggesting
that we cut revenue for businesses I'm
suggesting that what is left over from
revenue if it if it's over three million
dollars that goes into the pocket of the
owner of this Enterprise
that that 300 million and one dollar
yeah gets taxed 90 cents let's have fun
with this so here's a question for you
uh and and I kind of know what your
answer is and I want to be clear on
something yeah I'm doing this I I
subscribe to this not because I think
that we need the money or that this is
going to you know be a Panacea in terms
of like how we would spend this money
yeah but I see in this country a massive
problem with wealth inequality and the
commensurate uh political inequality
that comes with it we have wealth
inequality in this country like we've
never had before I don't disagree so so
there's not a disagreement there but the
solution is where we're going to
disagree so let's kind of process that
together okay so you know the whole
thing like I remember when I first got
out of the military and I went into the
financial industry It's 1999 I know
nothing it's 2 000. I know nothing about
now the Speaker gets up well have you
been noticing that the rich keep getting
richer and the poor keep getting poor
I'm like okay my dad's at a cashew at a
99 Cent Store 15 years my parents got
divorced twice I hope you said to that
guy You Ain't Seen Nothing Yet wait to
20. but you're right completely out but
you're right though but but why is the
question so here's the question for you
so you're saying about three million you
know that money that the owner's Gonna
Keep we got in tax on 90 fine okay so
you believe the money like when I was in
the military you would buy a product for
the Humvees and they would say yeah you
know we pay 600 for this piece right
dude this piece is 40 bucks right why
the hell are we paying 600 for well you
know the contracts you know how they are
man the government always pays a lot
because they're dumb they always pay
more than it's usually worth a forty
dollar piece for a Hummer they're paying
600 I'm like that's an awesome business
for the other guy yeah we have we have
horrible oversight but this is the point
though this is the point and I want to
actually sincerely get your thoughts on
this on how we address this so
if if somebody overpays for a product
that person's either got to be fired or
during overspender or terrible
negotiator but it's one of the three
right okay so you feel money going to
the government we do more good with or
money staying in the free market for
people to produce more value where do
you feel values produce more well I'm
not I mean I I
I'm not sure I fully get what you're
saying but I let me put it in this way
it's a very serious simple question I
wanted to be clear let me make it a
little bit more concrete so you guys
know that the biggest part of the budget
more or less is uh Social Security and
Medicare right Medicaid yeah and and
Medicaid entitlement programs yeah I
mean yeah you can call them entitlement
programs I call them social insurance
um uh programs because I know Tomatoes
that's what they really are I mean 90 of
the budget I want to say no the military
is is about 850 billion Social Security
is like 1.7 trillion I think uh Medicare
is probably going to pull up the charge
700 billion and then there's other yeah
so but it's a high number it's a big
number you're right it's the high number
you'll find that that's it it's I think
we're our annual budget is somewhere
around like 2.7 trillion and and the
military is like 800 800 billion 900
billion you know that that you can see
anyways that they show it yeah but um uh
but nevertheless
Social Security Medicare the two biggest
things that the government does are
wildly popular Medicare you come from
the insurance business you probably know
this to administer health insurance
there's like 13 15 cost in the
administration of that health insurance
for Medicare three percent
far more efficient far more efficient
and co-pays are less
I mean and the
uh the the whatever you want to call it
consumer satisfaction I don't like to
think of citizens as consumers but the
satisfaction is huge through the roof
particularly people use it it's even
it's people appreciate it who don't use
it you know if I got my parents they're
on Medicare I'm pretty psyched about it
because I don't have to take care of
them uh my mother's in a nursing home
now it's Medicaid that's doing that I'm
not responsible for that cost
Social Security through the roof in fact
I think even Republicans I think even a
majority Republicans want to expand but
it's a hospital popular is not a way to
qualify something if I if I want to meet
you satisfaction if I went to high
school and I said guys I'm giving dime
bags of to everybody wheat I'd be a very
popular so well that is a wrong way to
qualify well you said efficiency yeah
Medicare three percent right
administrative costs versus 15 it's like
the kid that's running for class
president is like every Friday we're
throwing a pizza party well he's gonna
get everybody's vote but who's
performing for the pizza party well
workers in fact I would argue that we
should be actually
removing the cap on Social Security
taxes because right now you know it goes
only into 160 000 right there's a cap
traditionally social security
has captured or touched 91 percent of
the country's income you follow me and
now it's somewhere down in like the mid
80s because of welcome your argument on
the on the flip side of it the argument
can be as well to say well at the
beginning when they came out with Social
Security
there's only a few thousand people in
America that was actually using it it
was not meant to be for as big of a
behemoth like what it is today it kept
two-thirds of our of our elderly out of
poverty it keeps two things
that's not the argument the argument is
originally when it came out it wasn't
for well the Creator had to wait you had
to wait no no no no no you didn't have
to you had to have capitalist work and
over tax them to be able to fund it
that's what you had to do but let me go
back to the things what you are saying
just to validate your point I think at
that point this is FDR back yeah we can
pull up the data I think there was 40
workers for every retiree I think now
it's closer to like three workers yeah
no no no it is sustainable you think
it's no no I don't think it's
sustainable I'm looking at the Social
Security Actuarial with the letter when
they sent you when they sent you this in
the Social Security letter they're
telling you if we go this way this is
going to go bankrupt no no no you miss
reading it the trust fund is going to go
bankrupt in 1981 Greenspan and Reagan
expanded the trust fund we had a surge
of baby boomers there is a trust fund
that exists that is essentially like a
rainy day fund that is going to go that
is going to be insolvent
around 30 33 20 33. no sorry twenty ten
years you are correct I just had this
conversation this last week however
however however that's not a concern it
is it is a concern it will cause 20
percent in cuts to our benefits okay but
that's it period now the way that we can
get rid of that 20 in Cuts in this
social security trust fund is to do what
I'm suggesting remove the cap so that
every dollar you make
even above 160 thousand dollars is taxed
by Social Security and then your kids
will be long dead before that
transformation if I raise my kids right
my kids won't need to be supported by
that they don't need to be yeah if they
don't need that social insurance I mean
how can you as an insurance guy how can
you not understand that no no I I don't
sit around saying like you know I hope
that I don't need my uh fire insurance I
hope I don't if your kids don't need
Social Security old age insurance
I am better for society I am better for
society if I find ways to get people off
of needing any of this stuff then to
rely on it more and more and more
because I'm truly hurting those who are
creating Commerce that's why I'm hurting
but let me go back to myself
for you let me ask a question before you
still haven't answered my question for
me no no wait
you still haven't answered my question
let me go back to the question too okay
my question question at the beginning
you have not yet answered okay when you
said you know I would go back to the old
tax system and I would take you to the
50s and 60s where we had a ninety
percent okay and I asked you a question
I said who do you think produces more
value I gave the example of the Humvee
the pieces and the Army how much we were
paying 600 but the piece was only forty
dollars and the government tends to
overspend because they're Reckless
spending they don't really they're not
really held accountable does money going
in free market create more value or
money going to the government create
more value for people explain to me what
you mean by value okay so value to me is
uh you know if if I can if I can give
money to free market and lower taxes
where they can go create more jobs more
opportunities is that better for us long
term or is it better for us to raise
taxes to take away incentives and give
that money tax money goes to politicians
to make decisions what to do with the
money are politicians better at making
decisions on what to do with our money
or are we
um I mean I guess unlike uh in a broad
way I would say if we're going to look
at the biggest chunk of money in the
government to make this assessment right
1.7 trillion dollars Social Security
and we can compare it to the one sort of
like comparable thing in the private in
the private sector and that's a 401k
I would have to say I mean just based
upon your the way you set up this
question that obviously the government
because Social Security
has been the single most effective
program that we have in this country it
has kept uh two-thirds of our senior
citizens out of poverty as a social
insurance program
401ks have been a disaster
they've been a disaster just Google
right there in front of you the 401K
experiment people took the money out I
mean and Grant you like you know you can
make an assessment that these
individuals were stupid or immoral or
whatever it is I'm looking at
the goal of keeping senior citizens out
of poverty the government has been able
to do that far more effectively
two-thirds of our seniors
are in nursing homes because the
government is paying for it
you can look around at anything that
doesn't involve a profit motive like for
instance the post office if we didn't
have a a government run post office do
you think you could live in you know the
the most rural parts of the country and
get postal service for 42 cents or 48
cents you can send a letter no way what
what person looking to make a profit
would do that in fact I've got a great
example this is you know I was doing
radio during Katrina
and there was a story that haunted me
for years and years
the uh when when Bill Clinton I'm not a
huge fan of Bill Clinton's uh uh uh
Administration frankly but one of the
things he did do well was to build up
FEMA I guess having come from Arkansas
you had a pretty good sense of what was
important there and Bush when he came in
very early on privatized a ton of it
there was a story a very small story
um in New Orleans the buses that was
supposed to come to New Orleans to
evacuate people before Katrina hit
there was a whole ton of buses that was
that went through three different
contractors right there was like a
general contractor and then a
subcontract another subcontractor was
going to bring the buses they were from
like three or four hours away
and uh maybe maybe it was six hours I
can't remember the exact details
they were going to send the buses but
the the guy whose job it was who owns
the bus company and then the contractor
above that they waited longer because if
you send the buses and they're not used
they're going to eat that cost right
they're going to cut into their profits
they didn't send the buses they didn't
get there in time people couldn't get
evacuated would it have changed the
trajectory of the thing I doubt it but
it would have saved some people and the
point is that there are some jobs that
the government does better because the
value there is not measured in terms of
actual shared dollars it is measured in
you know essentially how much miseration
are you inhibiting people from suffering
and so I you know like yes I agree that
when it comes to auditing in the
military worst the worst government
agency we have because it's very easy
very hard to sort of like scrutinize the
military uh people don't like that and
it's also a huge power base of a lot of
money they make a ton of money out of
this I agree with that same
well listen the numbers don't lie three
percent administrative costs for
Medicare can I just make I I appreciate
some of the points you're making I do
think that you're kind of conflating a
couple different things I think to Pat's
question
whether the government is better at
spending your money or whether the
private markets or private companies are
better it's not even close if private
companies are spending money like soda
or to actually like just direct it in a
way that that keeps less people from
okay we have 31 trillion dollars in debt
right now I think that's evidence enough
Sam that we're not so good at spending
money here in America
politicians spending money we're not
good at management manage a better word
yeah okay there's a difference between
being Frugal and being smart with your
money and just being wasteful the
government is clearly [__] wasteful
where you are correct is that most
retirees and most Americans do
appreciate Social Security do appreciate
the entitlement programs that come with
this country whether it's Social
Security Medicaid Medicare no doubt but
that doesn't mean that government is
good at spending money we're seeing that
Social Security is about to go bankrupt
no trust fund is going to trust
responded by 2023 and yes I just had
this conversation literally two days ago
in DC where he kept using the word
bankrupt bankrupt bankrupt I said what
does that mean who kept using that word
Republican music it wasn't even a
republican he was sort of a Social
Security Financial Advisor expertise
type of guy but I said what do you keep
saying Banker is that meaning that
retirees will not be receiving benefits
he goes no they'll probably be slashed
by 25 you use 20. so we can you know cut
the baby in half here
but are you how familiar are you with
the three-legged stool of retirement of
course yes okay so it used to be you had
three Avenues to retire you had pensions
which do they even exist anymore for
they they 90 people more as a defined
contribution than uh than Define they're
not very popular these days I don't know
how many people here pensions you have
social security which was never meant to
be a retirement program it was an
insurance policy if you live too long
which basically Americans are now or you
have your personal savings which is the
401K we can argue the merits of 401ks
and Roth IRAs what have you but Social
Security should not be keeping Americans
afloat for 30 years of their life well
that's enough of the Private Industry
isn't it why is it a failure for the
Private Industry well I mean Social
Security is maintained it the the idea
that we're leaning on the government uh
uh um um stool because the other two
have failed that's what that's okay
then a function of just the average
person understanding how money works and
saving money investing and doing it
properly versus the government or
institution of of the country lives
paycheck to paycheck how are they
supposed to save this money
well how are they spending their money I
guess is the biggest question how many
people have credit card debt how many
people you just said when you took on a
mortgage you said I'm an actor what was
the rate you're like I don't [__]
even know you should know well I was
making so much money that I don't give a
[__] how much money you've got King Sam
you should know what your mortgage rate
is but you know I mean I I didn't
remember what it was in 1998 but I mean
I can I know what it is now but I mean
um but I was making so much money but I
was making
I I was in the top I don't know I don't
know if I was in the top one percent at
that time but probably pretty close let
me ask you a question I had I was a
single guy who had just gone from making
you know uh to twenty two thousand
dollars a year to all of a sudden making
that how much are you making a week at
that point I mean I was making a lot of
them now how comfortable at that point
would you have been paying 90 taxes
sure so you actually want to pay I'm 80
in taxes no no no
I think it should be 90 over for the for
the every dollar you make over three
million yeah that would not have been
that would not have impacted me at that
time so but I would have been happy to
pay more taxes
you know why I'm laughing because it's
always uh it's always uh let's tax the
people a little richer than me it's
always let's talk about richer
if you're saying I'm just going back if
you're saying 22 a week you're making a
million in 98 that's a lot of money no
no no well it wasn't twenty you said 22
a week that's a million years no no that
was the year before I mean I I but
you're making money let's just I was
making a bunch of money so so but I'm
just going back to when we had the great
compression which was when we had the
least wealth inequality in this country
we had the same the GDP was you know
consistent with they're you know on our
trajectory but it was spread out it
wasn't like this essentially it was it
was going it was more spread out it's
called the Great compression and I'm
just using that figure I mean look
if it's going to be 85 percent over 3
million or 85 over 4 million I'm just
basing it on what was the most
successful economic why not Europe why
not of this country why not do 90 over
250 000 I mean if if if if the numbers
beared out I I'm I'm agnostic as that
I'm just Peg on when we had the most
success in this country in terms of our
economy I I appreciate that you're
pointing out the success but right now
the top marginal racks federally is
37.39 okay
you do realize how shocking it is to say
all right rather than go from 37 to 39
if how about 40. how many how about 50.
how many people you want to go to 90.
how many people do you use how many
people do you assume would be touched by
that tax would be implicated top one
percent I look at this number right here
share of total income taxes paid less
the top one percent in this country pay
42.3 percent the bottom 50 only paid 2.3
so 150 million people are paying nothing
in taxes right and you want to keep the
one percent paying more and more I think
it's actually even less than one percent
to be honest with you I think we're
talking about 0.05 let's tax them even
more oh oh I specifically want to make
it illegal to be
almost as wealthy as you not quite but
but but a little bit more like I want to
make it not not illegal you're not going
to go to jail so nobody can be no
billionaires no bills no millionaires in
America absolutely Sam 100 why why don't
you want America to be known for
greatness for Innovation for capitalism
my definition if you want to go to like
Nordic socialism my my definition of
greatness is different from yours I'll
give you an example why I think
billionaires are a problem
uh
uh this country's public school system
has been
um hopefully not fatally derailed
because of an experiment that the Gates
has did
they sunk about 750 million probably
about a billion dollars directly and
then multiple billions other sort of
like subsidiarily into an experiment in
this country for Education it was done
primarily up in the Northwest but it
changed the whole trajectory of
Education in this country value-added
high-stakes testing all of this they did
it up in the in the Northwest it
impacted everything Obama's uh Secretary
of Education pursued this
in New York we had high stakes testing
et cetera et cetera in 2017. okay this
for two decades
shoved a lot of teachers out of the the
industry people who love to teach but
then they lost like their ability to
because everything had to be taught to
the test and and there was no sort of
like real thought going into education
everything was prescribed
2017-2018 the the gates is higher the
Rand Corporation to make an assessment
of of their to almost 20-year project
which derailed education in this country
and the Rand Corporation said
unequivocally big mistake
should have listened to Educators and
and uh
big mistake don't do it anymore and and
basically the problem with billionaires
in my estimation is that on a whim
whether you know his intentions are good
or bad or whatever it doesn't matter no
one should have the ability to impact
Society in that way unilaterally we
don't have kids but neither we don't
have Kings right we live in the best
system that we possibly can have which
is at this point which is like as much
democracy and we could have a little bit
more right there's still some
minoritarian aspects of what we're going
through but but democracy is better it
involves more stakeholders in it it
brings more people in who have
investments in this you cannot have one
person decide on a whim I'm gonna derail
uh public education in this country for
decades you just can't have that we we
got rid of uh of oligarchs when we got
rid of kings and Samuel you said and not
to go let him because that while you
were saying that same I was looking at
the chart for the spending when you're
talking about the education look how
small that little chunk of education is
because they love to keep us stupid but
look at look at our defense and I go
when we're in debt and we say that thank
God we're spending that much money and
you know why all the money that we owe
the most money to China you would say no
China and Japan China in Japan no no we
owe the most amount of money of our
federal debt over 60 percent of it is to
the US government so we owe ourselves
yes basically that's correct we owe
Social Security what point were you
making my point was making like thank
God we're spending that much money
because whoever we do all this money to
can't come and get it you don't see
nobody coming oh you're talking about
military military defense so your
argument is that so much money let me
get back to your um your how a
billionaires or even
multi-multi-millionaires should be
abolished or illegal as you said I think
you said that sort of illegal in tongue
but but I but I do think that we should
have a structure that that you can't
amass let me let me ask you this uh
Sam how long you've been doing your your
show my the majority report
um I've been doing like talk radio for
18 years majority report though well it
was the majority report on on on radio
but as a podcast it's been it'll be uh
12 13 years okay great and you have how
many subscribers on YouTube
a million subscribers a million miles no
he's bigger than a million no you're one
1.5 are you not like a closer to why do
I think you're right are you trying to
attack some more Pat no no I think he's
had phone taxes he's over a million I'd
say 1.3 1.3 probably let me pull it up
um if you can pull it up to see okay 1.3
million Subs yeah how how
big do you want to get that how big do I
want to get it ideally how what's the
gear Target goal in the next 10 years
what would you love to get to retirement
what what how many subscribers would you
say again I honestly
honestly five million the only
difference that makes to me is that my
kid is excited cool
um and are you comfortable sharing how
much revenue a million subscribers makes
how much like we get in terms of
advertising yeah just in general like
what's your
top line revenue for a big Channel like
this it's in the hundreds of thousands
okay uh now let's say you got it up to
five million let's just say you want to
get retired you want your kid to be
proud of you
and here comes Spotify
or Here Comes Rumble you probably
wouldn't be comfortable with Rumble but
like come here comes some big media
outlet that says Sam you're killing it
dude you are killing it we want to give
you uh a 250 million dollar deal to take
you you Sam Cedar will get a 250 million
dollar deal congratulations you got to
take all your stuff off YouTube we're
gonna put you over onto Spotify sort of
reminiscent of a Joe Rogan type deal
okay you're a few years away you're not
there yet but you'll get there what
would you say if they said we want to
give you 250 million dollars how would
you feel comfortable accepting that kind
of money
um sure I mean I don't know if I would
it would take it I I mean I don't know
if I would want to actually go on to
Spotify to get behind a paywall let's
say YouTube wanted to give you 100 if
somebody came up to me and gave me 250
million dollars sure you would take it
well yeah of course so by your own logic
should you now go to jail
what
if if if if you made 250 million dollars
I am saying that I believe the tax rate
should be the top marginal tax rate
should be over about three million
dollars about 90 so if they give you a
form if for your deal if the taxes are
the 75 million dollars a year yes I
should go to jail okay that's fine what
if the taxes are at that level and I
don't pay the taxes that's why you're
talking about tax evasions but now I'm
not saying that people should go to jail
because they make a lot of money
I'm appreciating the joke but what I'm
asking you is totally
appreciated
I just don't want my guy going to jail
if you made 250 million dollars should
be structured in such a way that people
cannot have a billion dollars or that
they cannot amass enough money where
they will be have that type of political
power I don't know if you're more
concerned about power if I could yeah if
I could say this like you know if you
think about what is the greatest case
study in the world ever right and we
rank the top 10 greatest case studies
there's a lot of them right what the
case studies could be but one of the
greatest case studies in the world is
how this you know group of 50-something
men came together who were not happy
about what was going on in Britain and
they started this idea in 1776 and they
wrote out the Federalist Paper the
Constitution you know etc etc
and then that went and turned into this
behemoth
of a country that positively impacted
the world technology that's being used
around the world and it validated that
the best economical system in the world
is capitalism
um
if it allowed people to go out there are
willing to work and how big of a dream
they wanted to build and how big of a
life they wanted to build you kind of
leave them alone you know if they put a
limit on how big of a YouTube channel
you could make you can't have a YouTube
channel over 10 million I mean you know
you wouldn't have PewDiePie you wouldn't
have Mr Beast maybe you'd be happy if
you didn't have these guys I'm not too
familiar with those guys but let me just
say this though but if what you were
saying was true right I mean if we were
real but it is going to base it well it
is I mean this is the greatest case
study ever well but if you really want
to look into actual I mean if you're
really looking at that case study right
you got to say
um this country and you know
it is what it is but the idea uh that
this country was just simply capitalism
and it was also it was a tremendous
amount of free labor that was used to
harvest a crop that made Northerners
wealthy Northern financier is wealthy
shipping magnets wealthy
um and it made obviously the plantation
owners wealthy now we would never
Advocate that you should have of course
slavery today of course we wouldn't but
but but so to go back but wait wait a
minute wait a minute you can't say
something like that and give the black
guy to the country because that was done
in practically every country in the
world so it was a very but here's the
part I don't want to I don't want to
debate the the the this is this is what
I would say was slavery unique no no no
the point the point I'm trying to make
to you is if that was accessible
everywhere okay well no it wasn't in
most countries they had a form of
slavery at one point also didn't have
the confluation between slavery cheap
labor and the fertile ground to grow
cotton for instance for instance let me
just give you another example of like of
this because you really if you if you're
going to talk about American history and
I'm not this is not about America is
particularly uniquely evil because their
slavery was uniquely worse than someone
else you know granted we had chattel
slavery which was not as necessarily
popular or other places but that doesn't
matter the bottom line is if you're
going to make an assessment on how this
country grew
put aside like you know the the feelings
of ego or hurt feelings that it makes me
feel bad as an American whatnot if you
want to just look at it coldly all right
you look at something like the Trail of
Tears the reason why we have the Trail
of Tears and killed all of those uh
Native American people is because
plantation owners in Georgia and Alabama
wanted the fertile ground that had been
given uh to those uh native tribes
because it was fertile ground they could
grow more cotton there when when we
basically eliminated those Native
Americans sent them on the Trail of
Tears
the number of slaves grew exponentially
because these plantation owners got this
raw material which was the fertile
ground they brought in Free Labor to uh
to harvest it the hardest part of of
cotton uh of dealing with cotton is the
harvesting of it I mean this is part of
the system and you know I'm not saying
that America is uniquely evil because it
or unique
you're saying that I'm not saying I'm
saying that I'm just looking at the I'm
saying the greatest case study Patrick
I'm just looking at the cold hard facts
and if you're going to look at it as a
case how do you have to make that
assessment that is part of it how do you
free labor how do you adjust business
how do you judge a great idea succeeding
what's your way of judging a great idea
what's my way of how do you like let's
just say we come up with an idea okay
and by the way the idea could be as
small as hey moving forward Sam I think
what we need to do with your YouTube
channel what's the goal
uh what do you mean what's the goal well
if I'm going to measure a great idea I
want to know what the goal is because I
feel like here's the thing no no no and
I don't mean this I mean this with all
due respect yeah but I feel like your
assessment of a of of a great idea or of
a great thing of this is measured in how
many dollars no I never said that I
never said that no I'm not all of your
examples can you play along instead of
assuming just play along instead of
assuming and jump into conclusion I'm
going to give you the respect give me
the respect as well how do we judge
agree how do you judge a great father
how do I judge a great father yeah how
do you say he's a good are you a good
father I I try to be okay I try to be so
I don't know if I am I don't know if I
am quite frankly you and I are not going
to know for good Fathers I think for
another 30 years you know we'll find out
if we're a good father well what would
be the measure like if you want it like
like what is the metrics in which you
measure no problem so so let me let me
ask you this way okay to me uh how do we
judge a great show on YouTube how do we
judge a great restaurant how do you
judge a great uh I don't know a great
movie how do we judge a uh a great party
how do we judge a great nightclub how do
we how do we judge any of those I wanna
this is what I would love to do this you
write down how you judge a great show on
YouTube and I write down how I I judge a
great uh show on YouTube and and you
know restaurant movie and I guarantee
it's going to be different oh oh okay so
how do you judge a great restaurant I
mean I I great restaurant I'm not so
great when it comes to food but I would
say like a great movie for me is uh is a
function of like maybe how much emotion
I feel or how many insights I get from
it
um and are they doing something that
impacts the the the cultural language of
film I mean that's the way I would joke
so I would say one of the best ways to
judge how what country's done it the
best around the world is how many people
can wait to go there and if you judge it
based on that America's kicking
everybody's tail I'm an Iranian guy I'm
from Iran you look at the amount of
immigration I went through a refugee
camp to come here dude my parents got a
divorce my mom's in town last night or
now we're having a conversation till
late at night we sacrificed a lot they
sacrificed their marriage language
barrier all just to come to America okay
my mom and dad never said what was the
situation in Iran
a pretty shitty situation in Iran but
also why did well we had a lot of others
I'm in Honduras we had 100 but we had
195 other options why do we come here
why don't we go to Russia why don't we
go to China why don't we go to Venezuela
why don't we go to Cuba why don't we go
to Germany why do we come to America why
is America leading 4X number two 40 plus
million people that want to come here so
you could say well you know it's because
that's not really a right way to measure
it because if you think about this this
that why do so many people want to come
to America I think I think there I I
mean I I think because there is a a
promise
I don't know if it's kept many instances
is not but there's a promise of more
Economic Opportunity certainly depending
on where you come from it's it's it's
pretty clear like I mean if you're
coming from Honduras
um there's an uh there's there's more
Economic Opportunity it's also
theoretically safer right than than
Honduras is many of those people also
have relatives that come here I mean
there's a whole host of reasons you've
got also a um a tremendous mix of people
here so there's a community there's an
Iranian uh why are they coming here
though well why did they come here
because it's a lot easier to drive to
Russia than it is to drive to U.S I
can't even drive to you it's a longer
flight well I think it's expensive
democracy too got it so because of what
the founders created a system where I
could come here as an atheist when I
came here I was an atheist I didn't
believe in a God I didn't think God
exists if a god really exists why would
we have all these wars in Iran that
makes no sense to me good for you weak
people that you think you need to go to
I don't need it and then later on in
life at 25 years old I made a different
decision but nobody judged me if I was
an atheist when I was in the Army nobody
said anything to me I yeah no but I was
I was Iranian I went in the Army yeah we
had some jokes we made fun of each other
truly like people made fun of each other
but we got along I feel like you
misinterpreted why I was explaining that
the the uh how the the economic power
was built in this country I'm not saying
that America is bad that's not my point
are you saying this is the greatest case
study of a country in the world ever
the greatest case study yeah meaning
meaning meaning that that when it comes
down to show an opportunity no other
country has done it better than America
as based on what it was founded on I
mean you could argue that like you know
the our Mobility numbers certainly at
times at times
that's why I want to go back to that
that's right because the time where we
had the most mobility in our society now
granted we still you know in the 50s and
60s if you were black you didn't have
the same civil rights obviously uh I
mean you know you couldn't engage in
Commerce in the same way you couldn't
you know uh
country's always going to make progress
we keep getting better it sounds like
you want to make America great again but
just tax purposes
when I go to the when I when I think
about the the the the the greatest
expansion of the economy for the most
amount of people it was during that era
so let's go this was a great job so
we'll say this here we go uh I am uh I
do appreciate Donald Trump the defending
Social Security and Medicare I don't
believe necessarily that he would do
that if he got into office but I
certainly appreciate him doing it side
note for selfish reasons did you watch
the movie The Whale I did do you like it
yeah I had mixed feelings about him I
actually used to be friends with uh the
director and so I can sometimes sort of
see I I it's hard for me to sort of
separate what I'm watching but um I
thought it was I thought it was was
interesting I thought it was a terrible
example for parents to watch and kids to
watch Dad gave up on the kid it was a
very difficult movie to watch I thought
Brandon crushed it I am so happy to see
that guy do what he did what an
incredible performance to do with it was
a great performance I thought that was a
10 of a performance very Redemption is a
great story to see but anyways did they
win no they didn't win I think the movie
that one was the other everything
yeah I thought performance wise and he
crushing okay let's go into Trump let's
talk about some Trump topics here and
let's transition into that because we
got 35 more minutes I'd like to hit a
couple other topics here oh [__] my page
is missing pages let me see if I can
find it I would like to go to yeah this
is better I would like to go to
uh the story about what's going on with
him and you know how he said Tuesday I'm
gonna get arrested all this stuff let me
read that story
uh uh where is the story on that but
first of all I'll just ask you the
question so what are your thoughts about
what's going on right now with him you
know the New York
getting them to get arrested and all
these deep fakes have come out if you
can show some of the pictures Rob on the
Deep fakes that uh they're showing you
know I mean you got to give them credit
for what they're doing go to the next
one you know you got more here and then
keep going this is he would never run
like that by the way there's no chance
he's running that's not happening they
look younger keep going yeah I mean but
but
this is right now and my cousin Ryan was
just at one of these conventions
AI producer is that Trump is a cop by
the way
no Milani is really pissed off yes it is
true yeah
but I didn't even know I can't go here
yeah
you're under arrest but uh my cousin
just went to a convention where he's
with all these AI programmers and stuff
and they're like yeah we're having
problems just you know with the fingers
and stuff but can you imagine this is
just random in five years the propaganda
machine just can be insane like Sam I
have a video of you and it's prove to me
that you weren't here stabbing or
robbing or running anything it's going
to be a disaster yeah I agree totally oh
my God Sam and just the just the the
trying to approve yourself is like you
weren't your innocence is going to be
insane and I'm not going to be really
nuts oh God I think it's going to be bad
both ways by the way that 100 you know
what I mean both ways what do you mean I
I mean the other side guys are going to
be like nah that's not me that's a deep
fake yeah I think it's gonna be oh yeah
both used against you in and out where
the lawyer is going to come in and
they're going to say yeah that's not
really him that's a defense that's what
is known as the Shaggy approach the it
wasn't me it wasn't there you go
so so okay so this whole thing are they
you know the conversation from the left
or the right or people in the middle who
really are like I don't know what's
going on they're right they're targeting
them because they want to eliminate a
competition and they've been trying to
do it so many different times the left
no this guy did break the lawn let's go
get him arrested because he is this he
is that where do you where are you at
with this scenario I you know I a uh
I've always sort of like looked at
criminal cases you know even from like
even before I got into this and and sort
of felt like I I let Jerry's decide I
mean it's not unprecedented that
somebody would like John Edwards went
through something very similar to this
um in his race he I think was ultimately
acquitted but I don't know how the
details are different but I mean look
this one
you know as far as like am I offended
that he paid hush money to uh you know
someone he was having an affair with or
something like that I mean you shouldn't
you shouldn't lie on your business forms
right I mean you know that I mean it's
it's illegal if you do that if they're
Prosecuting them the they're the
prosecuting of a grand jury indeed some
grand jury indicts him I don't think
that he should get off because he's a
former president
um I think the one in Georgia is
probably a lot more serious in terms of
an offense towards our democracy uh and
we'll see what happens with that I mean
so
um does it help him does it hurt him you
know some people say Elon Musk is like
he's going to be there this is pretty
much going to guarantee him winning the
election where are you at with that with
what's going to happen I think it
probably helps him in the the Republican
primary
um I uh I I don't I think he was going
to win the problem you know I think he's
going to win the Republican primary
um I think in the general election it
remains to be seen you know there's
there's so many factors I I had
predicted very early on that he would
probably win the Republican primary in
2016. I was not I did not protect
correct predict correctly in the general
election I can tell you that but um uh
yeah I mean look he has a very solid
base of support and
um I think the my experience of the
conservative movement and the
conservative mind is that uh a
grievement is a big motivating factor
um the there is always like some
argument of you know
uh you know uh I I I have to use other
pronouns it's an imposition on me or
um the whatever it is the gays marriage
is an imposition on me or Muslims are an
imposition on me or whatever it is is an
imposition on me that agreement drives
it and this is why I think he knows
there there is some value to get out of
it at least he's using it for
fundraising I don't think he wants to be
indicted I don't think that's a pleasant
thing he got to expend money on lawyers
and stuff like that
um but my guess is it would probably
help him I mean DeSantis in this morning
console poll I saw I guess yesterday
maybe the day before he said his lowest
ebb
he went up and then he went back down I
think the more he goes around people
don't like him that much and I think I'm
not terribly surprised by that I feel
like you could see that with like
Giuliani and Scott Walker these were
people who were very popular in their
own
uh area or at least there was a
perception they were very popular and
then nationally they just fizzled out I
mean I don't think DeSantis is I don't
think there's really a lot of evidence
that DeSantis is as popular as you know
coming out of Florida you'd probably
know better being here but
um you know I look at his vote tallies
in the last election he was running
against a horrible candidate who's lost
in every single party that exists yeah
Charlie Chris is one of the worst
candidates in the world I don't know why
they bring this guy out and DeSantis you
know basically performed in the same way
that Marco Rubio did
um there's no way better than Ruby no
Rubio won by like 1.3 million votes 1.4
million and I think DeSantis one by 1.5
1.6
I mean Charlie Chris is a horrible
candidate I mean I mean just horrible
and the Democratic party in Florida is
really really weak I mean it's not doing
a very good job as an institution
um and so I don't know that the uh I I
think that there's
um you know but we'll see I mean I
I think it I think it may help him may
hurt him I mean it's going to hurt him
if he's in jail
do you think it'll get there anything
it'll get there it's hard for me to
imagine yeah but I you know I don't know
what like you know the people are saying
like Biden should step in we the same
people who complain that Biden some type
of dictator want him to step in and tell
a district attorney in Manhattan don't
don't prostrate that who's who's saying
that who's saying for him to step in
yeah oh God I mean you see it all over
the place I saw Tucker Carlson at the
very least I know you know was
articulating it two nights ago Biden
should step in and what pardon him I
don't know what is the president
supposed to do but about a charge in New
York yeah there it is yeah begs Biden to
stop indictment for the sake like how
does he do that yeah
yeah yeah in a big way I think I think
it's more you know what is happening is
it's the same thing with Tate right a
guy takes Andrew Tate's lawyer on I
don't know if you follow his story I had
his lawyer on right so anyways but I
said with a guy like this you know every
month he gets an additional 30 days for
six months so he's going to be 180 days
of keeping him in the Romanian jail they
could have done it in April of last year
but they delayed it until October or
whatever month it was when they did it
November when they arrested him
and it's allegedly allegedly allegedly I
said if
they don't get this guy this time and he
comes out he's gonna blow up and even
more because it's going to be every time
you try to get me to blame you for
something and it's not coming true you
got to stop and His Image gets bigger
and bigger whether it was Russia whether
it was whatever they've tried so many
different ways to get this guy Trump and
his audience then says well I told you
they're just targeting this guy they're
just targeting this guy they're just
targeting this guy and and the mega
group not all the other Republicans
rhinos but the mega group was like dude
these guys are targeting him so the
support form is going to get bigger and
bigger each time they do this my
question for you I think that should be
a concern of prosecutors I don't think
that you should I don't think you should
I don't think so no if you've got a case
score for it I'm not telling you to do
or not if you got a kiss but by the way
if you got a case you gotta also go
after Hunter Biden if you got a case you
also got to go up there is the charges
well I mean they're investigating yeah
if you do if you do finally you should
go Accord if you got the laptop don't
say we don't have the laptop and not
look through it there's a part of that
that becomes favoritism question for you
would be to follow it do you think I
think
which is more likely to happen Okay and
the scientists let's just say wins uh uh
not the general but he wins the primary
okay let's just say he does okay the
chances are slim you know CPAC was 20
Trump 60. I'm just saying let's just say
that happens okay okay what's more
likely to happen for desantis's Camp to
support Trump if Trump wins the primary
or Trump's Camp to support the same
obviously are you kidding are you
kidding no Trump's not going to support
the scientists
like I mean
here's my question though do you think
that there's a is there uh a percent
like a possibility that the Santas
realizes okay this cat Trump is going to
win and then doesn't even announce that
he's gonna you know that's that was my
thinking up until like uh a month ago
it's a very good question this guy I
mean I mean if I was DeSantis I would
say I'm gonna wait yeah and be maybe be
the vice president well because I don't
think he'll be VP though if he becomes a
shocker he won't become VP Christine
Christine gnome it's going to be
somebody else not Carrie like I don't
think Santa's is Young he could wait
four years Trump is out of the picture
uh there's an open there's no incumbency
uh in the president incumbency is very
helpful regardless of who the president
is more often than not
um I think he's got a much better shot I
mean he's going to go up against Trump
and in in this Republican party I mean I
don't I think once is gone like
literally gone yeah like Departed the
planet
um then I think there's going to be an
opportunity for other people in the
Republican party but he has a hold he'll
still be tweeting on Thursday even when
he's gone he's like it's like
Blockbuster you're not Blockbuster
retweeted
yeah I mean I he has a big hold on the
party because in many respects the party
was really
um
was was training itself to uh Embrace a
guy like Trump for years and years okay
so did you see DeSantis on Pierce Morgan
have you seen the interview yet or no I
haven't okay so I think this is like the
first time where he he went at it a
little bit I don't know if you saw any
of that so I'll I'll go to this article
it's an answer I got Trump's though uh
uh truth social what he wrote that was
fantastic
it's hilarious fantastic which one are
you talking about the gay the men and
women thing or which one are you talking
about no he he wrote uh you find it I'm
gonna read the story The Santos breaks
the silence on manufacture circus around
expected Trump indictment I don't know
uh what goes into paying hush money to
porn star uh again Republican Governor
DeSantis criticized a Manhattan jury
investigation to president Trump's
expected I don't know what goes into
paying hush money for a porn star to
secure silence over some type of alleged
Affair I just can't speak to that and
then he follows up and he talks about
how it's not fair what they're doing and
it's a circus and all this other stuff
but that is a shot that he took Adam and
then boom here's Donald Trump Ron the
segment that sanctimonious will probably
uh find out about false accusations and
fake stories sometimes in the future as
he gets older wiser and better known
when he's unfairly and uh illegally
attacked by a woman even classmates that
are underage or possibly a man I'm sure
he will want to fight them these
misfitsches like
[Music]
that is hilarious he he went even harder
on uh DeSantis uh last night and
um basically just did all the op you
know the um
the Oppo research you need I mean it's
it's a long thing but he goes like you
know uh reread the whole thing now that
Rhonda sanctimonious is finally
admitting he's in the race by beginning
to fight back for some reason he
capitalizes I don't know why he does
that yeah and now that his polls also
capitalizes paid but I won't stop every
time he does weird capitalization has
crashed he has no other choice because
his polls did crash uh let me explain
the facts he is for Republican and
average Governor he got 1.2 million less
votes in Florida than me he fought
massive Cuts in Social Security and
Medicare and wanted Social Security
minimum age to be raised to 70 years old
or more I can't tell you how
excited I am that Donald Trump is like
like like splitting the Republican party
in half over the Social Security
Medicare I really can't I mean I I don't
I don't trust that he would maintain its
Integrity if he got into office right I
mean I'm still waiting for his his new
health care plan that was like only six
weeks away from being revealed uh eight
years ago but I'm really happy about
this he is a disciple Paul Ryan and did
whatever Ryan told him to do I was also
not a fan of Paul Ryan Florida has been
successful for many years long before I
put her on there and it's amazing what
ocean and sunshine will do surprise Ron
has a big lockdown Governor I mean he
goes on and on I mean he just basically
says like all the problems with Florida
um uh in education Florida ranks worse
amongst the country in crime statistics
Florida ranked third worst in Murder
third worst in rape third worst in
aggravated assault for 2022 Jacksonville
was ranked as one of the top 25 major
crime cities in the country with Tampa
and Orlando not doing much better on
education Florida ranks 39 and health
and safety in the country 50 in
affordability 30 in education hardly
greatness there I mean this is his tweet
what was that was a trip
yeah and it sounds like they need some
limits from you have to understand from
my perspective right like I I think that
Donald Trump is is a danger I happen to
think that George W bush uh you know
arguably did a lot worse I mean he
killed hundreds of thousands of people
on a lie
um and but
um you know Donald Trump really
destroyed parts of the administrative
state that I think are problematic
rolled back this uh banking thing that
we started with your phone roll back the
uh the banking
um uh provision that is causing all this
problem right now
um but I have to say I like a guy who's
out there saying don't touch Social
Security and Medicare and I like a guy
out there who is like uh cutting against
the the whole myth that New York City is
particularly violent our crime
statistics are down like 69 from the 80s
from 1980s so like it's like 70 years
our friend Rudy Giuliani well I have an
alternate Theory because some months if
you want to look at crime nationally and
internationally when 20 years after they
got rid of leaded gasoline
we know lead is a neurotoxin right uh 20
years after both nationally and
internationally if you look in in cities
crime dropped precipitously so it was
the gasoline's fault it was lead which
is a known poison neurological poison
the story LED distant gas is also just a
horrible story of corporate malfeasance
I don't know if you've ever heard this
but
um they knew from the beginning
that that led additive was
um yeah well there's the you can either
Sam back to your initial point this was
an endorsement for Trump
in The Green Room does Trump have your
Vote or no oh no no he doesn't have my
vote but he certainly lost my well
wishes
from the grave so pal was before we came
in I was talking to to Mike who's who's
uh back in the in in the booth like uh
my thing with the with all the
investigations from Russia it's all that
DNC with Hillary and one of the
Democrats going to realize two things
number one Lee if you leave this guy
alone like the Santa's husband just
don't even give him all these all these
DA's and everybody's trying to corrupt
why doesn't the Democratic party instead
of trying to just go after Trump with
all this false [__] that is making
his base riled up find the candidate a
viable likable candidate to go against
this guy so they don't have to do all
this FBI [__] you know trying to get
the guy like why not have a good person
to go against I don't understand when
people characterize it as the Democrats
doing this like Alan Bragg is a Democrat
but what is what is the what is the DNC
or you know Joe Biden supposed to do
about a Manhattan D.A what is he
supposed to do about all the prosecutors
in Georgia who are Republicans I mean
that's the real case that's the real
dangerous I fully agree with the Georgia
case yeah Georgia's whole different
situations and listen if Trump had just
returned the freaking documents when he
found them and when he was asked I mean
he they were asking him for months and
months and months just give us the
documents back he wouldn't do it and the
guy wouldn't do it he lied to his own
attorneys about having them he'd be fine
nobody cared about that the whole thing
was the cover-up essentially in that
case I mean I don't think Democrats want
to focus on Donald Trump I mean I I
frankly you know for me as you know I I
I'm a registered Democrat but it's more
or less so that I can vote in the
primaries I more or less vote against
Republicans is what I do but
um have you ever voted for a republican
I'm probably have on like a very local
level uh you know when I was living
Upstate you probably haven't if you
don't remember well I mean there's
nothing wrong with it sometimes there's
only one person running and if there's
only one person running for like you
know County supervisor but but on a
local level a local level I mean I can't
name every Democrat I voted on a local
level on local level things have gotten
much more nationalized with with
politics even on a local level let's go
to let's go to the next story go go pull
up the clip of G and uh Putin talking to
each other I'm curious to get his
feedback here if you have the video clip
it's on Twitter
uh you can find it it's all over the
place when they're talking uh but if you
want to finish your thought you can
finish your thought while he's finding
this video
let me talk about something yeah yeah I
just really fast oh there you go you
found it okay good make that bigger so
this is G and Putin talking if you can
go back so you can read what they're
saying uh okay there you go if you check
the audio to see if we have the audio
changes coming that hasn't happened okay
can you hear it change is coming that
hasn't happened in the first 20 years we
are driving that change together but
because
Asian guy speaking Russian that's crazy
who is saying that that uh that's a
translator that's uh that she's telling
uh in this but his translators
is it or is it the No No the the the
Russian the Asian guy is that she's
translator he's translating in Russian
make sure to tweet smart to find out
who's saying this at this point yeah it
sort of is important very important yeah
yeah
that's she that's she's a translator
which threw me off because I'm like yo
that guy's by the way I mean look can we
watch Putin wave goodbye like uh 16 year
old girl let me see it's missing his
boyfriend please watch this let me see
bye it does it four more times bye I
love you watch this and even as he drove
off jog down the street yeah it very
clearly shows who's the boss in that I
mean but that's pretty cheap that's
pretty scary though same like like to
see these two guys two of our biggest
like adversaries coming together and
doing like a hey like it's gonna be good
from now on it's kind of a scary that's
a scary ass moment if you ask me I mean
I I am really
um uh I I I I I I am really reluctant to
um to get too like engaged in in wanting
to have a conflict with China I mean
this has been coming for a couple of
decades back when I was doing uh radio I
interviewed Gary Hart Who Sat on a uh a
commission right before 9 11 on the
greatest threats to the United States in
the 21st century and they had a
commission of about I don't know like 30
40 people had them lined up what do you
think is the number one threat to uh the
United States most the people said
non-state actor terrorists that was
pretty prescient some said state state
supported terrorists one person said
China this is in 1999 or 2000 and
um
three months later they meet again same
thing happens everybody laughs at the
person in China that person never came
back onto the commission wow it was Dick
Cheney's wife and I'm quite convinced
that for a long time the uh
neoconservatives you know uh primarily
in the Republican party but some I think
in you know the Democratic party but
primarily in the Republican Party have
been you know worried about China uh and
it's all about economic dominance
um and I think that like
uh you know we had the Asian uh pivot if
you remember back into what you probably
were aware of this in uh in the in the
Arts where our fleet was moved to the
Pacific from the Atlantic
um and we've been gearing up for this
conflict with China basically to protect
the interests of uh multinational
corporations particularly American
corporations and that's what the TPP was
all about
um and I you know I'm in favor of making
sure that we have uh supply lines and
Logistics you know moving and having
production uh you know uh on short but I
also like think that like we should not
be getting into a war to protect the
interests of some corporation who's you
know who's not necessarily providing
benefit to the United States per se how
how do you how do you see this in in
regards to uh Ukraine and how this
affects Ukraine does this show you know
hey uh uh Ukraine us all the proxy
awards that you're causing look who's
teaming up with me now XI is this going
to change the strategy of U.S and NATO
towards Ukraine or this doesn't do
anything there
um I don't I don't
own anything in the context of Ukraine I
mean I I
I I I would I understand why we we we we
probably wouldn't hear of what the exit
strategy is but I think that we should
have some type of exit strategy in terms
of support for Ukraine I agree at the
same time
um this is not a a fight that the United
States picked I I am someone who who
felt like we shouldn't expand NATO
um in fact I think I was somebody who
was feeling like we can start to sort of
maybe disengage on some level NATO that
is now obviously off the table because
you know
Putin if if he was worried about NATO
this was the worst thing he could have
possibly done it seems to me uh was to
give everybody in Europe a reason to uh
be supportive of of NATO but
um look we made a deal with Ukraine in
93 give up your uh your your nukes and
we will protect you
um and
uh i i i
as long as we don't have regime change
uh and as long as like we uh there's you
know some like sort of clear-eyed notion
of like how much
um uh territory Ukraine can get back I
don't know that we're gonna go to
pre-2014 borders
um but at the same time also you can't
you know I wouldn't want the look I was
against the Iraq War
I'm against uh uh Russia's invasion of
Ukraine same same argument like I'm not
I'm not convinced that there was a
imminent threat to Russia from Ukraine
uh that that brought about their uh
their attacks on on are you in favor of
the amount of support we're given
Ukraine right now
you know I'm of two minds of it I mean
you know I think like obviously we need
to provide them uh some support but I I
do worry about how deep our engagement
gets I I think that like if you're Putin
you're waiting to see if Donald Trump
becomes president
because
um if Donald Trump becomes president
then you're quite confident that all the
funding is going to dry up and you stay
into that war
The Dilemma that the bide Administration
has they have to show like overwhelming
commitment that would like surpass that
would go beyond uh even if Donald Trump
becomes president
um and and so why do things some may say
uh if if Putin is waiting for Trump to
become president because the funding
would dry up for Ukraine to get weaker
why didn't he attack Ukraine under Trump
because he would have never supported
you he thought that he could get Ukraine
without having to be military and go in
militarily do you think I think he
thought that Trump was going to deliver
him Ukraine I'm not convinced that I
mean you had manafort on didn't you or
something like that yeah we did yeah
yeah we did have it he would have been a
good guy to ask why uh yeah why Putin
very interesting guy to have on oh yeah
I would imagine he's very smart but uh
but from all that that's going on from
all that that hooking up with you know
she and poo and just was it yesterday
right after this meeting or was it
before was threatening he's like if the
if the West sends tanks or any depleted
uranium or anything to to help Ukraine
fight that war he's like nuclear
components and attack well like now this
guy's threatening like he threatened you
know early on too I mean the problem
with backing down from a nuclear threat
is that it becomes all of a sudden like
licensed to whatever you want if you
have nukes I mean
um it's it's it's a dilemma I don't
think the bide Administration wanted
this by any stretch of the imagination
in fact the reporters no did not I think
the reporting actually was that the
Biden Administration was convinced that
Putin would take over Ukraine within a
matter of days and with a week and then
the problem that or the Dilemma they had
or you know for many in the in National
Security State I think they saw it as an
opportunity was that Putin was not doing
well yeah and that Russia was a bit of a
paper tiger and then at that point it
gave it opened the door of an
opportunity for all these warhawks and
these people who want to make a ton of
money by selling and Manufacturing
weapons you know what I wonder I wonder
I'm sorry let me just say this I wonder
if you know how you feel about Iraq not
just you a lot of people on both sides
feel about Iraq and how it was a waste
of a war and then the way we got out of
it and it cost us another 83 billion
dollars we can go and talk from many
different angles I wonder
what people will say about our our level
of support to Ukraine 10 20 years from
now I am so curious I'm so curious if
it's going to be another one of those we
should have never gone in or it's going
to be we should have gone in more or if
Trump was President this would have
never happened or the motives the
intentions the reasoning uh I don't
think a hundred percent we're gonna know
what's really going on there for a
minute yeah and I think we can and we'll
never know what would have happened had
we not provided Ukraine with the ability
to stop uh Russia from making it part of
a Russian Empire and where would would
um Putin's
um uh interest end at Ukraine certainly
there's there's countries around there
that don't feel that way well revisiting
your comment about
uh how much support Biden has given and
why he's doubling down and sending
yelling and sending uh Lincoln and
selling all the latest was Merrick
Garland he just he's doubling down on
this why do you think that is well I
think I think if I'm Putin I'm thinking
that you know I'm gonna wait I'm gonna
wait because if the administration
changes it's it's a change right like
you know if you don't like uh your
situation that's an old edict right if
you don't like your situation you wait
and see uh you know there's going to be
a change coming or possibly and this is
Biden trying to sort of like signify
that we're not going to do that there
was reporting about back moot where the
the bite administration had told uh
Ukraine
you've got to cut your losses in back
moot because it's just not strategically
necessary and you don't have the ability
to do it you don't have the ability to
take over Crimea you don't have the
ability to do this you just don't our
our analysts think that you don't have
the ability to do it and uh but then you
know uh it it was almost like that got
too much publicity and the Biden
Administration can't show that level of
weakness they need to show full
commitment so that Putin thinks they're
in for the Long Haul I don't know this
is like these games are horrible five
minutes left let's do a quick Speed Run
what are your thoughts on musk what he's
doing his impact Twitter
uh just Elon Musk period what are your
thoughts about them I don't know double
the amount of anti-Semitism according to
a report 40 percent loss of uh of AD
Revenue as of December
I I you know I find it a lot less
interesting of a place frankly uh uh
Twitter you know long term long term is
it gonna is it gonna end up being a I
think he's a bit of a charlatan I think
he sold a bunch of like I think like a
lot of he's got problems with his uh
with
um uh the the Tesla and I think that
like he's all you know he's admitted
that his whole hyperloop stuff was just
a way to uh crash public transportation
he wanted to crash that high-speed rally
we've successfully helped uh derail it I
think that's not in the best interest of
society uh so is he in that positive to
society no come on you don't think so
you don't think he's in that positive to
society no so what do you think about
all his like Twitter files and all the
showing the people like what the what
the government everybody's really doing
behind the scenes like is he a wolf in
sheep's clothing especially like with
that situation like with the AI I think
he he selectively leaked uh stuff on
Twitter files I think it's a problem
when the president of the United States
tries to silence some somebody they did
this with the Smothers Brothers Nixon
did it back in the day I mean yeah I
think that's bad but I don't think that
we see the whole story about what's
going on there oh I agree with that what
do you mean by that what do you mean by
that
I don't know I mean if you were gonna I
mean he's gonna do what's in his
interest right I mean he's going to
release what's in his best interest to
release he
yeah but some of the stuff about how
they you know the New York Post story
was held back and Twitter getting the
emails and Matt taibi I'm sure you know
who Matt taibi is of course for Matt to
come and for him to say Matt's not a
republican Democrat yeah for him to say
oh I mean Matt is a contrarian reporter
and I think you know Matt also said that
he felt that uh Russia gate was
equivalent to the weapons of mass
destruction lie and to me that's you
know
I I think you could argue that you know
uh parts of the media got it wrong but
it wasn't even remotely close I thought
that example you don't think Russia gate
was wrong no no he's saying the level of
of what I mean come on you're talking
hundreds of thousands I get what you're
saying they're saying the comparison is
is a berserk too yeah yeah it was a
threat to democracy I'm saying this is
like the the Snowden releases of the NSA
I'm sorry this is a private company you
know as a business guy I'm sure your
public relations people called up local
channel five and said don't run that
story yeah you know that happens all the
time should the government be doing it
absolutely not but could Twitter have
announced something could have Twitter
at that time said the FBI contacted us
we're not going to give him this
information they could have yeah and
they didn't what are your thoughts on
Jordan Peterson uh I think Jordan Venus
is a lunatic and I think I think his his
perspective on uh on on women is just
Twisted
um he might be good for you know helping
Wayward uh kids who don't know how to
make their bed but I think that I think
that a lot of his ideas are really
incredibly toxic and bizarre frankly
what is it on women specifically oh I
mean just the you know I'm not a uh a
Jordan Peterson of file but I just
remember the last thing that uh had
talked about that he had said was he was
speculating that perhaps it was a
detriment to women uh not to not for men
to have some
form of ownership stake I think he was
talking just sort of like you know
broadly like loose investment in
relationship with them to protect them
from uh from rape
both statistically that's bizarre but
also the idea that like when and it
wasn't that long ago that women were
chattel of their husband let's say in
this country or uh women were property
rape wasn't even a crime against women
it was a crime against the owner of
women so like it's his stuff is
completely a historical and why do you
think he has such a massive following
and what do you think about his
followers I mean I don't know his
followers I don't know who they are I I
imagine their their young people but I
mean I think there's there's a bunch of
reasons I think that look this is a um
it is a society is in a period of
transition of uh because people who have
been marginalized uh for the at least in
the context of American society
um have more of a voice particularly
through like social media and this and
that but also um I think like there's
more of a voice in terms of like
there's not as much hostility from uh
law and this and that was only 2013 when
when uh there was marriage equality in
this country
um and I think there's also a um and I
think that it it makes it hard for some
people to understand where they fit in
and I think there is a very strong
message from fundamentalists in this
country religious fundamentalists who
are
um you know white knuckledly holding on
to their system of the way that uh
society and families and people should
be organized and uh their interpretation
of gender and whatnot because it's it's
all perceived as a threat and and so I
think within that milia and and then I
think there's other factors in terms of
like money there's there's money that
that sloshes around on the right that is
helpful to things that push their
ideology so I think it's a combination
of all those things I think I think
Jordan Peterson you know you you can't
ever be a hundred percent
um uh accurate on everything that you
say without offending people you're
going to say some stuff that's going to
offend people I think he has helped a
lot of young boys
who have been lost the last 10 20 years
know a little bit more about what it is
to be a man the the endless amount of
stories of how that guy positively
impacted people's lives is uh is it's
the numbers unbelievable how big it is
where I mean where did you I've heard
you say I think uh sir someone told me
that you you you're a data guy whereas
like do you is that just anecdote
anecdotes or uh go have you ever filled
up an arena with 15 000 people no but
Andrew Dice Clay did the 30 000 but the
difference is the difference is we went
to Andrew Dice Clay for comedy but
people are going to Peterson for other
reasons well that doesn't necessarily
mean it's having a positive impact on
society I think for men to be stronger
is a positive impact on society in an
ERA with so many uh fatherless homes
that they don't have a man giving them
direction thank God someone has given
them directly well I I worry about that
guy if people want Direction they can
come to me
well that would be a fun case to see you
give mindset to 100 boys and him give
mine says to 100 boys and we see what
happens 20 years later it's yours by the
way and it'd be an interesting one by
the way last one here another guy
another guy you could afford to set that
up I would be open to it another one is
another one is Jimmy Dore we have Jimmy
on we had a lot of fun with him I didn't
know a lot about Jimmy and then
everybody said hey Jimmy same way
they're saying about you I'm having a
lot of fun having you on I have Jim I'm
an interesting guy what do you think
about Jimmy well you know Jimmy uh and I
I don't know that we were friends
necessarily but we were simpatico and
then in like uh 2016 uh he was saying uh
stuff on his show I think he was back on
tyt at that time he had another show
he was okay with Peter Thiel being a
Supreme Court Justice he was talking
about how Donald Trump was going to
resurrect the Democratic party and
Donald Trump will get elected and if he
gets elected we'll get Elizabeth Warren
in in 2020. I mean these were all things
that he had come up with and you know I
I sent them an email I said look you
want to come on my show we should talk
about this because I think a lot of that
stuff is crazy and he said no no no and
uh so I started you know I said go ahead
rip me a new [__] and so I I played
the clip and then he must have been
listening to the show because I take
calls I take live calls unscreened calls
that's cool every day and uh he calls in
and we have a debate and the guy Jimmy
called in yeah Jimmy called in from his
car I guess and and the guy didn't know
anything about what he was talking about
he didn't know what a filibuster was he
made all these predictions he said I
said look dude you get a Donald Trump in
there there's a chance you get three
Supreme Court Justices he says uh you
you that's like the the moon could fall
into Lake Michigan well it turns out the
Moon fell into Lake Michigan
and and we're going to feel the effects
I mean for people I don't know if it
necessarily bothers you guys but for for
for me the idea of like not just rolling
back abortion but the the Voting Rights
Act
um uh I mean government agencies that
have the ability to do stuff I mean it's
massive I mean it is a tidal wave I
don't think the American public totally
realized that could have been the single
biggest thing a president has done to
help their party the last 60 years or it
is the worst thing for the opposing part
McConnell I think gets that credit
because McConnell was the one who would
not even have a nomination hearing they
controlled the Senate would not have a
nomination hearing he kept that that's
that's McConnell that's McConnell I
think that is the most under uh
understood reason why a million years
would I have guessed you would have been
a supporter of Mitch McConnell that kind
of credit Sam I was ready for a lot I
wasn't ready for this one you you shook
me a little bit like I said well we're
about to be done who do you think
besides Biden does run again if you can
even make it who would be the Democrat
right now yeah Sam right now if you have
to pick out of the entire Democratic
party pool who would be I know it's
early as hell but who would be their
number one me and Adam who we still
haven't made this bet we were we betting
that um Gavin newsom's gonna be their
number one no that's what I mean look I
I there's nobody I can name that I would
want to be president yeah in the
Democratic party right now but I think
that it it more than likely it's someone
like uh pritzker uh in Illinois
this is I'm not I want to make it clear
yeah these are not my this is not my my
picks this is my uh your analysis yeah
yeah I would say pritzker Whitmer
um and uh you know maybe uh Shapiro and
Pennsylvania
um I would say those would be the ones
that I would uh if I had to place a bet
yeah it would be one of those three
these are not I should say these are not
my picks they're just you're guessing
these are like I have to go uh bet you
know my kids 529 on it
fantastic uh podcast really enjoyed
having you on if you want to find more
about Sam's podcast hey Rob can we put
the link below please so they can go
find it put it in the chat put it in the
description put it at the top so they
can go find them do you want people to
go to your website or you want to go to
your YouTube channel uh whatever is
comfortable okay you're right there it's
a good looking guy
I am a little bit lazy when it comes to
promotion I gotta be honest I'm not the
best business go to YouTube go to the
website you'll get better whatever yeah
people find it so so we we are uh uh
announcing today in the text who is
gonna be on the April 6th live podcast
if you want to find out who it is to
purchase tickets at our next building
the comedy club and the Cigar Lounge
text award podcast
to three one zero three four zero one
one three two again text award podcast
not podcasts some people are doing
plural singular podcast to
310-340-1132 in less than an hour we're
gonna text that group and let them know
exactly who the guests are going to be
on that podcast live looking forward to
seeing many of you guys there Sam once
again appreciate you for coming thanks
for having me appreciate it take care
everybody bye-bye
Sam very nice